for our first question
we have a general question here pastor
skeet the question is asked
what is righteousness by faith
righteousness by faith is the central
doctrine of the bible
it is an expression it is equivalent to
conversion
it really is the new birth the
conversion that is righteousness by
faith
it is the process whereby christ
imputes to us his righteousness when we
are fully surrendered to him in
acknowledgement
that we cannot save ourselves and we
absolutely need him to save us when we
surrender that to him totally
then christ imputes to us his righteous
life
elowhite expresses it in steps to christ
page 62 paragraph two
if you give yourself to him and that has
to be 100
and accept him as your savior then
sinful as your life may have been
for his sake you are counted righteous
christ's
character stands in place of your
character
and you are accepted before god just as
if you had never sinned and this is seen
in the sacrificial system in leviticus 1
verse 4 and he shall put his hand upon
the head of the burnt offering
and it shall be accepted for him in
others the offering stands in his place
and the offering is without blemish and
without spot so when he brings that
offering
he is accepting the fact by faith that
this righteous spotless life of christ
now stands in his place because he has
surrendered
himself to god it's a remarkable bible
teaching
that the righteous spotless life of
christ
is given to the one who surrenders to
christ 100 and so when those two men
went up into the temple to pray
in luke 18 the publicans said in verse
13 of luke 18 god
be merciful to me a sinner jesus said
i tell you this man went down to his
house
justify having received an experience
righteousness by faith but
keep in mind faith and works page 100
paragraph 1
god requires this entire surrender of
the heart
in other in order for justification to
take place
and in order for men to retain
justification
they must be continual obedience through
active living faith that works by love
and purifies the soul justification by
faith
is that remarkable process that only god
could have come up with
whereby the righteous life of christ
is imputed to the sinner who sees christ
as his only hope
you